- Two work outs, six hours.
Yeah, somebody's got to it.
Also just tied my
shoes which is unheard of.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Whitelines" by K.A.A.N)
- [Gary] I would
argue everybody
in theory, there's nobody
you can't have as a customer.
So the reason for $700 I would
go to a meme account that has
3 million followers on Instagram
to do a post is just the sheer
volume of attention for
that $700 is gonna
create distribution. Got it?
I don't know why I did it.
Uh-huh, yeah, I'm Gary.
Yeah, because I'm winning that
whole businessman personality
thing and all the other guys and
girls that are trying to win,
they're doing it full time.
And so, a lot of times
I'll make fun of them,
'cause they're my
friends, you know I'm like,
"You know that GaryVee
is my side hustle, right?"
- Yeah, like VM.
- You know?
So, so they're
always like holy shit,
that's true.
- Yeah.
- Big fan.
- [Gary] Thank you, mate.
- You're awesome, man.
- Thank you.
- Take care, man.
- [Raf] Do we need
to go to reception?
(group chatter)
- [Gary] More stuff to back it?
Yeah.
- [Marcus] And not just the
cases but just the infrastructure.
- Well, we're gonna be able to
do more of it because I'm gonna
hire a lot more against it so
it's just gonna keep
giving them more assets.
- Right.
- [Man] Gary,
when did you get in?
- [Gary] I got in yesterday.
Yeah. Latte is great.
I got in yesterday.
- [Man] Yeah?
- Are you guys doing any
marketing direct to consumer on
behalf of the tenants
because you want to become--
- That's what
we're starting to do.
- Well, that's where we,
whenever you're a mature enough
to have that conversation,
here's my punchline.
- Yeah?
- Depending on how much you
do or don't know about me,
we'll factor in how much you
believe what I'm about to say.
My basic goal with this
company is very simple.
If a human who represents a
company gives me a penny,
that whatever the fuck they want
to happen I'll do a better job
with that penny than anybody
in the world and that's why we
don't deem ourselves
as social media shop.
We think we're a attention shop.
- [Man] Yeah.
- So, we have every capability.
Media, production,
creative, strategy
and it all comes
down to one thing.
Tell me what you want to happen
and then we try to go backwards
in spending the lowest amount
of money to make it happen.
- [Man] Awesome.
- Another successful
trip to London.
I think 30 hours this
time so pretty good.
Bunch of client meetings.
All client meetings.
All current clients and
a couple of
prospective clients and so
really excited about it.
My man here
coming through again,
doing his thing.
And yeah, nothing
super, you know,
I didn't give you a whole lot
of crazy footage this time.
A lot of meetings you couldn't
be a part of and just classic
running a business, you know?
When I think about DailyVee
365 episodes or the ambition of,
maybe 330 'cause
of family vacations and
things of that nature.
You know, some days are just
not gonna have
anything too exciting.
As a matter of fact,
most days shouldn't.
85%, and one of the challenges
that DRock and Other Tyler and
homies that we hang
out with like Raf here,
one of the challenges is really
figuring out how to at least
show the context of all the
meetings I'm actually having.
One thing I was telling DRock
the other day was like,
"Look, 80% of the time I'm
spending is on VaynerMedia
"meetings but DailyVee is not
showing that because we can't
"show so much," and
so, you know, right?
Think of, right?
Think of what
happened on this trip?
I'm running a business here.
I'm busy.
I'm running a business.
I'm in meetings that effect
other human beings and so it's
hard for me to show them but
you know I think it's a good
opportunity to let you
guys know there's a lot of
hard core day in and day out
business making that
is not being shown and
I'm gonna try to do a better job
to figure out how to interject
it even if we just show the
still of the meeting starting or
the meeting ending and we start
putting times and start putting
"Vayner Meeting",
"Vayner Meeting" because this
GaryVee shit is my side hustle.
I'm the CEO of the fastest
growing hottest 800 person,
700 person digital,
social agency in the world.
- [Rafal] Okay.
Just pounded through 600 emails.
Pretty intense.
So many themes,
so many entrepreneurs
thanking for the motivation.
You're welcome.
So many people
asking how to start.
You just start.
So many people asking if
influencer marketing works.
Yes. So it's like that.
People looking for permission.
That's what
I have to figure out.
People looking for permission.
I'll figure it out.
And I'll keep giving it to you
but you've got to figure out
how to give it to yourself.
("Conceled The Outro"
By K.A.A.N)
Rainy day here in New York.
I didn't know that 'cause
I never check the weather.
GaryVee never
checks the weather.
(DRock laughs)
- [DRock] Counterpunching.
(laughs)
- It rains, I react.
Dave Morin's got that one intro
to that female entrepreneur
sports media site.
I can do that.
How much time do
I have in-between June--?
Why don't I leave
San Francisco early and
get to L.A. Wednesday night.
And how am I getting to Miami?
Red eye?
No shot to do anything else,
no shot to catch
an earlier one, right?
Yeah.
Not too bad in
my opinion I think.
Like not the worst.
6:30 to 8 we get it done,
you know what I mean?
Unless we get a good
(censored) thing in.
You know?
Then I think James.
Chicago the 24th is fine.
Is (censored) ready to see us?
It works pretty good.
Okay.
It's amazing that I'm at that
point in my career where my
assistant is like an organ.
It's like so attached.
Tyler's doing an incredible job.
He's not been feeling well.
So, it's amazing how the pieces
just going back and forth
strategizing,
it's hand-to-hand combat,
it's a partnership.
It's amazing that one of the
things that a lot of people are
missing out on as an
entrepreneur who's had a little
bit of success, I know a lot
of you are just starting out,
but a lot of you are watching
and you have some traction
I'm highly
recommending assistants.
I'm highly recommending
teams around your content,
the DRocks and the
Andys in the world.
I'm highly recommending
the Office of the CEO types.
This Chief of Staff.
It may seem like a luxury and
something that you can't afford
but inevitably there's
always a young buck.
You know, there's a connection
to be made here in the
comments section.
44-year-old successful
entrepreneur who doesn't think
she or he has the luxury of
paying somebody $70,000 a year
to be their Chief of Staff and
really help them scale above and
beyond their right hand CFO type
or Controller or Bookkeeper or
COO type, their right hand
man or woman.
Meanwhile there's 50 to 100
people watching this right now
that are 22, 23, 24 that don't
want to do it the normal way
and that don't want to, you know,
wait seven or eight or nine
years to do interesting work.
And so, yeah, I see it's dark.
And so, are willing to
play that Chief of Staff,
Office of the CEO,
Office of the Founder role,
part assistant,
part content producer,
part COO, part psychologist
and I don't need
that by the way,
I just need compliments.
And so,--
- [DRock] You're
doing a great job, Gary.
- Thank you, DRock.
(DRock laughs)
And so, I think that we need
more creativity in the way we
structure our businesses.
I wish I did a
Chief of Staff, an admin type,
that character when
I was building Wine Library.
I had Brandon but he was
really Director of Operations,
he was really my right hand,
was too senior to do
the 43 things which were
22 little things like
schedule this and
18 things of like
follow up with this.
It's just a big deal.
I need to figure this out.
I've gotten an enormous amount
of value from my content team,
my admin and my Office of CEO
and it's the best investment
I've made in my career so far
and I'm looking to expand it.
I'm looking to make the
Office of CEO bigger over time,
the creative team's
getting enormously big.
We tried two admins,
trying to figure out
if we'll do that again but
I'm doubling up,
doubling up, doubling up.
(light music)